hello everyone and welcome to 1971
candidates match it's Game two of the
match Bobby Fischer vs. mark Temenos now
as you've seen in Game one Fischer
managed to win the game with the black
pieces and now whatever plant stem on
have had before the match and now after
losing in game number one he will have
to play it play it a bit differently as
he suffered a loss with the white pieces
so now he faces a fissure where Fischer
has the white pieces and we're not gonna
have a photo challenge as this game is
really really long and crazy and it
features an excellent story so we're not
gonna waste any time just to set the
mood here is a photo of Fischer in time
on of you know battling it out just set
to the mood now let's check it out like
we said Fischer has the white pieces and
he opens the with efore we have c5 this
is Cillian defense Knight to f3 Knight
to c6 d4c capture son d4 Knight capture
son before in e 6 teaming of opts for
the timeout of variation of the Sicilian
and here Fischer goes 4/9 to b5 it's a
tall says that it's not a move Fischer
will often play but here against the
amount of he decides to use it once
again as he also used it in the 1970
palma de mallorca inter-zonal tournament
against mark Temenos
if some of you are joining us only now I
will put a link to this game in the
description below if you want to check
it out
but after d6 tamaño repeats the
variation he played against Fischer in
Palma de Majorca Fischer goes for Bishop
to f4 and it's very interesting because
tal says Bishop to f4 is a move Fischer
last time played some 10 years ago here
in Palma de Majorca
he played c4 against I'm one of but
you're welcome to check it out in the
description so Bishop to f4 we have E 5
Bishop to e3 and here comes Knight to f6
I will just mention it shortly as this
is the position from the famous game
Murphy versus Anderson where Anderson
continued with f5 and after Knight to c3
Anderson continued f4 seemingly Murphy
has to move the bishop back but here
more if we went Knight to d5 and
sacrificed the bishop on e3
after a captures nice checks king of
seven Queen f3 check Knight of 6 and
Bishop to c4 Morphy created a beautiful
attack that ended in one of the most
famous miniatures in chess history but I
also made a video and that game so feel
free to check that out in the
description as well but let us get back
to this game the man who went Knight to
f6 Bishop to g5 Fischer already plays
for the third time with his dark squared
Bishop and here we have Queen to a5
check here there's a possibility of a
quick grandmaster draw after Bishop to
d2 Queen d8 rushing back to g5 Queen
back to a5 check Bishop to d2 what I
tamaño
will probably not be interested in a
draw as he did lose game number one and
Fischer doesn't even go for this after
this Queen - if I move he blocks both
the Queen Queen to d2 offers the trade
of Queens and here we have Knight
captures on e4 as the knight is no
longer pinned Queen captures on a5
Knight captures and now Bishop back to
e3 of course not not a knight and 97
check after King to d7 attacking the
knight Knight captures Knight will
capture and g5 and now you will not be
able to get this Knight safely back in
the game and of course this will not be
worth it
so after Knight a5 Bishop back to e3 by
Fisher King to d7 a very interesting
move you can capture this pawn on a 7
but here after Bishop captures d5 and
blacks play becomes a very strong as he
can get a lot of activity now so Fisher
doesn't go for this pawn grab instead he
plays Knight to c3 Knight captures
Knight captures and now King to d8
making room for the light square Bishop
Fisher goes nice to be five-year again
pressuring the d6 pawn but also
attacking the a7 pawn and here Bishop to
a6 Bishop to e6 displayed if d5 this
isn't really a threat now black white
can capture an a7 and this will be
alright so after a night to be five we
have Bishop to e6 and here at favorite
castles Queen side attacking the pawn on
d6
we have b6 and here Fischer has a lot of
options here for example he can
after only six winning the pawn back
immediately for example after captures
captures King attacks rook rook goes
back but to see for offering a trade of
the bishops but black would have a very
nice game here and it's hard to imagine
that white would push for advantage here
so after this b6 move another move
official can make is nice captures on a
7 now of course you're not gonna capture
the night and allow this Bishop capture
some v6 with Czech move after the
roadblocks first you're gonna capture
the night and then you're gonna capture
the rook but rather after Knight
captures on a 7 King to c7 now 95 check
King goes here and now basically we've
given your a pawn and now the King is
guarding the d6 pawn so the black the
the black rook an 8 will use the semi
open a file very nicely so instead after
this b6 move Fischer goes for the active
idea f4 we have B captors on f4 also an
idea was f6 for tomorrow but the dental
says that after captures captures and
the knife captures on d6 that d5 pawn
would be very hard to defend and here
Fischer could definitely push for a win
so after f4 we have ich a prison f4
Bishop captures on f4 and now comes a
night to b7 at a man of the amount of
manages to bring the knight back into
the game and now comes Bishop to e2 we
have Bishop to d7 pressuring Fisher's
Knight unbe 5 and now again Fischer can
go for something like Bishop to f3 seems
like a reasonable move but he will allow
too many simplifications for example
captures captures Ruby 8 and after
Bishop to d5 f6 now it will be a nice
position but Fisher thinks that the move
he played is better he plays rook to d2
preparing to bring the other rook to d1
and still keeping an eye on the d6 pawn
and here are what do you play here if
you play something like g5 not
immediately sorry about that first
Bishop to e7 was played Fischer double
rocks and the D file and now what do you
play here is black
well the d6 pawn is attacked 4 times if
you try something like Bishop captures
this was played in the game but if you
try something like g5
you get a bunch of captures on d6 Bishop
captures and now Bishop to b5 opening up
a discover to check bushel blocks and
now Bishop captures here on b5 the
bishop on d6 is of course pinned King
moves and now Bishop captures Knight
captures rook captures and white would
be up a whole piece with an easily
winning position after rook h2d 1
instead of g5 the best idea for black
would of seemingly be a six this is
something that tal mentions but still
after Knight captures and Knight
captures it's hard to see what to play
here but of course not capturing Daniel
Bishop to g5 first you have to move the
rook rook to d4 and here you see that
then I still cannot move as the bishop
on d7 is unprotected so here once you
play something like rook to e8 white can
simply increase the pressure there's no
rush for example Bishop 3
and only after you move the rook now
comes captures captures captures and
here again white would have a much
better active position but black could
still play this but instead Bishop
captures on b5 was played by Temenos
we have Bishop captures on b5 and King
to c7 rookie to Fischer now says that
he's done with the D file he wants to
bring his rooks over to the e-file we
have Bishop to f6 and now Rob D to e 1
doubling rooks on the e-file also
threatening rook to e7 check a beautiful
idea
for example if black tried something
like rook h2 d 8 then rook to e7 check
is coming Bishop captures rook captures
and now after King moves the bishop to
c6 and you see there's the threat of
capturing the 910 b7 denied there's no
way to defend the knight so after Knight
moves you would simply capture upon here
there's no there's no rush you will
simply you will capture this whenever
you feel like it you will simply gobble
up all of the pawns then capture the
rook and then win the game so a very
nice idea by Fischer after this rook D -
you won rook 8 2 CH time on off doesn't
allow this he gets his rook away from a8
we will push up the c4 attacking the f7
pawn and the rook h2 f8
that time on Ovie's an attacking player
a creative player and that he hates
Shirley hates playing a move like rook
to f8 having to defend this position
against Fischer and here fresh replace B
for a very nice move doll once again
compliments Fischer for for playing such
positions with such diligence now he
creates a wall here the pawn and Bishop
are not allowing this night to go to get
back into the game we have a 5 and the
now comes Bishop to d5 now attacking the
knight the threat of course again is
rook to e7 check so King to be 8 and now
comes a three keep him keeping an eye on
the b4 pawn rook F to d8 and now comes
Bishop captures on f7 terminal decided
to give up the pawn as his his pieces
are simply not active so well Fischer
was a busy driving a point amount of
manages to activate his pieces rush of
the c3 attacking Fisher's roof Bishop to
d2 now comes rook a d5 rook to d1 we
have d4 Bishop captures rook captures
and the NA comes to King to be to d3 a
very nice idea by tomorrow's King
chapters on c 3d capture sunny - and now
rope - you won of course you cannot
capture this even though it's with check
because after Knight captures your
Bishop is under attack and you do have
to stop from emotions so after King D -
yeah you're just gonna lose a piece and
now you're down a piece and you're gonna
lose the game
so after D captures on e to rook e1 and
now comes Knight to d6 attacking the
bishop bishop to h5 and here after at
all says that after defending is so well
against Fischer for the entire game here
at a man of misses a better idea here he
plays a Knights the b5 check but better
was a
tosses rook to CH check because now
after King moves now you play Knight to
b5 and now after c4 Knight to d4 check
and now the king will either have to
defend the c4 pawn by playing King c3
and you will play Knight b5 check back
again and then the king will either have
to move where you will continue checking
him or he will move back
then you'll continue checking him
because if he moves back you'll grab
back the c4 pawn so an improvement by
tal but here Knight to d5 with check
King to be to Fisher defends the a3 pawn
and now pawn captures on b4 pawn capture
some before and Dena comes look to d4
attacking the b4 pawn we have c3
defending and attacking the rook rook to
h4 with tempo attacking the bishop and
the d h2 pawn but it doesn't matter
Fischer plays rook Bishop captures here
and then now comes Knight to d6 there's
no time to capture the pawn as the
knight on d5 is hanging so Knight to d6
and now comes roofed d1 attacking the
knight King defends night and now h3 and
after all is said and done Fischer is up
upon but you know time on of should
still be able to hold this rope to f4
was played rook to f1 offering a trade
of rooks a tomorrow of course declines
this Bishop to d3 and the now rook to e5
we have looked to F to h5 & here after
giving the position some consideration
this is a move 45 prefer played c4 and
it was in this position that the game
was adjourned time on of decided that he
will play rook to g5 this is the move he
you know put in his little envelope and
he of course analyzed the position the
entire night and his seconds of course
analyzed that with him suggesting lines
but it tells us that Fischer that was so
sure of himself in this position that he
will win that he didn't really analyze
it all that much which will be
problematic for him here like I said
time on I went for a rock to g5 but if
you went for rook to e3 this doesn't
work it's an interesting idea but after
King to c3 now comes Knight to e4 a
check with an attack on
Fischer's rook an f2 but here Fischer
simply attacks the knife and the rook
and after rook captures on d3 which
check now of course not capturing the
route because you lose the rock with
check simply keen captures here and now
why they still up upon and with a much
more active King official would be able
to to prove
for the win so rook to g5 instead buy
time on off King to see 3 and we have
King 37 and now rope to a to going for
rook to a 7 of course a rockin the
seventh rank is where you want your work
to be King goes to c8 we have King 2d
for bringing the King into the game into
the center of the board King to c7 and
now comes Rock to a7 check also an idea
this was found during the game by Yuri
ah ba ba he suggests that h4 but it
seems that although it's an interesting
idea it doesn't really work after Ruby G
for checking d5 Rock captures here and
now c5 but here Knight to c8 and it
seems that black caused this and it
doesn't really justify the pawn
sacrifice so after King c7 Rock to a7
check we have king to d8 and here
Fischer played c5 this is what it all
means the one he says that Fischer
didn't analyze it you know too well at
home he was too sure of himself if you
ask the engine the engine will say rook
to a sex the best move and slightly
worse but still you should be able to
play the play this for a win his c5 so
the move Todd suggests is the engine
stop favorite the move Fischer played is
the engine second favorite but both
should be able to win so KB captures on
c5 b captures on c5 and not night to e8
the G to pawn is under attack so Fischer
defends it route back to a2 and now
Knight the c7 Bishop to c4 now we have
in 37 and now rook the B to the terminus
King is now able to come to c6 and after
King to c6 now Fischer will lose the C
pawn and there you see now that the
events of the c5 phone was a bit too
soon and Todd's idea of rook to a6 was
better in that position
Bishop to b3 and now Knight to b5 check
you don't want to play rook captures on
c5 because a bit of play for will win
you the game if you block then of course
rook captures and King c4 will pin for
the win for example if Knight captures
simply rook captures rook captures and
here you attack the pink piece of white
is winning
and of course after Bishop day for if
you move for example
King to be six then comes rook here King
as the move King captures rook it's game
over
so after Bishop to b3 Knight the b5
check by the amount of King to e3 and
now King captures on c5 we have King to
f4 attacking the rook rook to g6 and now
Bishop to d1 h4 we have pink to f5
attacking the rook rook to h6 and the
now King to g5 so here
Fischer's position is a bit better he
had the he does have a bishop against
tonight but everyone's you know general
consensus was that time on of should be
able to hold this Knight to d6 was
played Bishop to c2 now comes Knight f7
check King G 495 check King to f4 King D
for tomorrow also improves the position
of his King Fisher tries you know he's
very resilient he wants he always wants
to win and play you know up until the
Kings are bear rug before check King c3
rugby 5 attacking the knight Knight goes
back to f7 rook c5 King before and now
rook to f5 we have g5 time anova gives
up a pawn but he's able to simplify the
position into a draw
kingi 495 this comes with check on
Fisher's King King captures and now
comes rope to g6 check King captures and
now rook captures and g2 Bishop to d1 r
up to g8 and now Bishop to g4 we have
King to e4 and here came to g3 by
Fischer and it was in this position that
the game was adjourned again so the game
lasted for very long and this is one of
the few games pretty much you know out
of the more famous games very few of
them were adjourned twice
so here the game was adjourned once
again and it's the problem for mark the
amount of here is that this position is
a draw but as this position with this
game was adjourned here a game number
three was started and already finished
because before they continue to playing
game number two
because for example adjourned games were
supposed to be continued on Saturdays
and game number three was scheduled for
a Friday so game number three was
already over before they continued
playing game number two and in game
number three Fischer won a beautiful
spectacular convincing victory
and so after taimanov finally got back
to continuing this position he was
already down a two to zero in this match
and perhaps he didn't have time to
analyze it at home so much and you know
perhaps he didn't put up the resilience
that he could have so the game continued
rock the g7 by Fisher Rock to afford
this comes with two check sorry by a
mono rope to a fourth check by Fisher
King to d5 rook to a four Knight to g6
we have rook to a6 King and Knight goes
back King to f4 rook to f7 so this is
all still fine King D 5 we have rook to
g7 check King moves rook to f7 check
rogue blocks and here rook captures on
f6 King captures on f6 and this is the
critical moment of this game very rarely
that you will see such an important game
in such an important match to have a
critical moment and move 81 but here of
course this pawn you have to stop it you
have to go Knight 2 D 3 and then after
we go to f4 which is a dark square
whatever white plays doesn't really
matter once the night gets to a 4 it
will be able to prevent the knight from
ever reaching this square and this will
be this will be fine so what's the
problem here the problem is after this
King to f6 move at amount of played King
to a king to e4 and King to before is a
terrible blunder that loses this game
but you know feel free to pause the
video here and find the move that
Fischer played that I think that one is
seemingly drawn end game I will give it
a couple of seconds for you to decide
where you want to do it it's a really
important game in a really important
historic match so I guess you should do
it you know thinking about this position
and finding it will forever increase
your vast knowledge of this game and you
will for
know it so for those who were able to do
it congratulations on increasing your
vast knowledge and for those who just
want enjoyed show Fischer played Bishop
to c8 and now you can see that diamond
of mist that after night comes to f3 to
guard the h4 square Fischer has this
beautiful Bishop to b7 check move after
the King moves he will of course
eliminate the night and after the night
is captured then that is that is it it
doesn't matter if you don't capture if
you attack the pawn you can easily
simply protect the pond and then it's
again winning so after Bishop to c8 King
to f4 was played but now comes h4 and
again you don't really gain anything if
you play Knight to g4 here of course
Fischer will not camp capture he simply
came to g7 and only then will he
continue pushing the pawn as the point
is preventing the black King from
reaching g5
so after h4 Knight to f3 was played we
have h5 Knight to g5 now comes Bishop to
a5 a beautiful move putting black in
tubes 1 you can either move the King and
then Fischer captures the knight or you
can move the knight and then the pawn
advances Knight to f3 was played we have
h6 nine back to g5 and now another move
that puts black into swung King to g6 we
have knight back to f3 Fischer pushes h7
and here comes 90 to e5 check first
replace came to f6 and it was in this
position on move 89 that mic'd
marked I'm out of a resigned game number
2 and Fischer is now well I would like
to say two points in the lead in this
match but as this game continued after
game 3 finished Fischer is now actually
three points in the lead in this match
so that's a game number two I do hope
you enjoyed it and that you're enjoying
the coverage of this match so far I
already made a video on game number
three I think it's like a year ago
so I will put a link at the game number
three in the description below so you
can know if you're ready you can
continue watching it if not you know
watch it tomorrow or whenever so I
haven't seen that video for a while and
I will I will check it out if I'm
satisfied with how
did that video as I did not use any of
the taught any of Michael's house
comments perhaps I will even repeat the
video on Game three of the 1971
candidates match between official in
time on off but you know I'll still have
to decide on it so you know you're
welcome to check it out if you think
it's interesting and if it's alright
then you know you're right you know it's
it's fine you know you don't need to do
a video on Game three again and if you
think it needs work then i'll you know i
would even gladly do it again so like I
said that's it
I would like to thank Jamie commas for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate that as usual
you can check to my previous videos here
I will make one of them more fee versus
Anderson the game we mentioned in the
other one I will make facial versus time
on of the game from Palma de Majorca
that also featured the Sicilian if you
want to check it out so that's it thank
you for watching and I will see you soon
most likely with a remake of game number
three of the 1971 candidates match
between Bobby Fischer and Mark Simon of
thank you all and I'll see you soon with
hopefully another nice video